there's this idea oh you're going
plant-based so you're going to be
sacrificing your body's ability to be
strong which is a misnomer it's
misguided it's a myth first of all
you're eating foods that are much more
nutritionally dense like much more dense
in terms of phytonutrients and
micronutrients so you're actually
fueling your body with what it needs
secondarily you're eating foods that are
much more alkaline forming and
anti-inflammatory the more
anti-inflammatory your diet the more
rapidly your body is going to be able to
recover in between workouts it will
allow you to train harder recover more
quickly so that the next time you go to
the gym you can train harder again or
train longer you're less likely to get
injured or get sick and then miss
workouts so over the course of several
months or a year you're going to
experience greater gains than you would
otherwise